I was in catering and he comes up to me
and says so Lucas yeah are we doing
pressure
I was like looking around like well
I guess you know and he was like if
you're side of stage
then we're doing it so yeah yeah and
then I continue to do it every night
which
looking back on now I I feel so grateful
um to been able to shed those moments
with him from your point of view what
was so special about Taylor just how
disarming he was
I think most of the greats have this
trait where
they're not quite they don't quite fully
realize just how incredible they are and
I think that's why
he sort of like touched so many people's
lives is because he there wasn't this
big stupid like rock star ego which you
know can
be real for some people but for him it
wasn't so
um I think how genuine he was was
something that
I'm never gonna forget you know I just
miss him you know and whenever
I get like uh emotional about it I just
think how proud and excited he would be
for me today to be able to play with
both of our heroes is something that
nobody can take away from me so I'm
doing it for him